youtube what's good you're about to
watch a video of me doing a pop-up zoom
answering questions about nfts because i
had a meeting cancel and i can feel that
people want to know more
what's going on in the macro which is
epic and what to watch out for
in the micro can you explain nfts to me
but like in a simple way because i don't
i don't get it do you play video games
yes do you have you ever bought skins or
virtual things for your game
yeah that's an nft you wanted that item
to be a utility in a world that you
cared about
or as i'm sure you'll admit joe for the
clout
amongst your friends and other people by
having that thing
virtually that is going to happen to
everything in the world not just the
confines
of fortnite so literally everything
is has the potential to be a
non-fungible token
the metadata of access to humans to
companies
is the gonna be the game when there's a
nft chip for chipotle
and it's a golden burrito and if you
have it you get free for life
that's utility